des résultats positifs dans l'opération
comeau est conçu pour combattre le
terrorisme en afrique de l'ouest
les armées ivoiriennes et burkinabè ont
mené cette opération la commune alors
frontières au total huit terroristes
présumés ont été tués et 38 suspect
arrêté une base a été détruite
une première pour les deux pays qui ont
pu intercepter des armes des munitions
des prêts et usb ou encore des
téléphones portables une zone désormais
sous contrôle selon l'armée ivoirienne
qui se félicite des excellents résultats
on en parle tout de suite avec williams
à son nouveau chercheur à l'institut
d'études de sécurité
bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france à leurs opérations comme
où on rappelle ans et une coopération
entre la côte d'ivoire le burkina faso
on l'a rappelé c'est une première dans
l'histoire des deux pays
pourquoi c'est effectivement la première
fois que les trois armées ivoiriennes et
posa mais burkinabè interviennent dans
le cadre d'une opération conjointe au
niveau de la zone frontalière
cette opération répond à une évolution
assez inquiétante qu'on observe depuis
plusieurs mois avec les velléités des
plantations de groupe qualifié de
djihadiste lui terroristes dans le sud
du burkina après avoir déjà conquis un
certain nombre de zones dans la région
du sel au burkina dans la région du nord
dans la région de l'est
maintenant on observé au cours de ces
derniers mois des vélleités
d'implantation le long de la frontière
avec la côte d'ivoire mais aussi avec le
ghana donc c'est à cette évolution la
que cette opération conjointe ua entre
eux l'armée ivoirienne et armées
burkinabè voulait apporter une réponse
alors est ce que la côte d'ivoire a
coopéré avec le burkina juste pour
déloger avec torres de son territoire
est ce qu'on parle d'une opération juste
ponctuelle on peut parler d'un
partenariat qui va s'inscrire dans le
temps
je pense qu'il s'agit d'un partenariat
qui a été quelque peu laborieux au
départ mais avec cette opération et avec
les succès enregistrés et avec aussi
l'âme
ce qu' il y aura d'autres opérations je
pense qu'il faut s'attendre et pour dray
souhaitait que cette coopération perdure
sur le temps parce qu'il ne faudrait pas
considérer que ce avec une victoire
définitive qui a eu les coupes vont
continuer et l'ont déjà montré dans
l'aval par le passé vont continuer à
attenter et d'exploiter toutes les
fagnes et qui trouveront et on sait que
généralement les zones frontalières sont
des zones qui ont tendance à être
délaissés par les pouvoirs centraux
donc il s'agira véritablement ces deux
pays de maintenir le tempo de maintenir
la vigilance pour utilité de nier
d'éteindre toute velléité de retour ne
pas ce groupe
alors on dit depuis le début c'est la
première fois que la côte d'ivoire le
burkina faso coopèrent en matière de
lutte contre lui le terrorisme avec une
opération conjointe comme celle ci est
ce que les pays africains manquent pas
justement d'un peu de solidarité de
coopération entre 7 et vecsys
qu'effectivement un deux un des
principaux problèmes qui minent
actuellement la réponse apportée à ces
phénomènes d'insécurité
le fait que la coopération est très très
lacunaire et les positives et les
problématiques
il ya encore pour certains pays des
problèmes de confiance entre entre eux
20 30 relais entre les forces armées
entre les les forces de défense et de
sécurité
il ya aussi le fait que ça peut paraître
une évidence que passait un phénomène de
cette nature un phénomène transnational
et cette nature que la coopération
naturellement s'établissent ce n'est
généralement pas le cas il faudrait qu
il faut faire toujours preuve de du
d'efforts politiques des poids
diplomatique et des poires aussi au
niveau des ddd des fossés défense ou que
cette coopération veut s'établissent et
comme je le disais précédemment
et c'est un effort à maintenir sur le
terme parce qu'il ne s'agit pas à la
suite d'une opération qui a été
qualifiée de succès de baisser les armes
et de penser que le problème est réglé
il s'agirait effectivement pour ces pays
de continuer à maintenir cet effort de
coopération et de collaboration
ce ne sera pas toujours un long fleuve
quand il mais c'est un défi auquel les
pays les pays compte
né de la zone doivent faire face
justement parlant de coopération
analogie cinq scènes un mali tchad niger
burkina faso et mauritanie c'est un
cadre institutionnel de coopération
justement comment jugez-vous son action
à ce que vous pouvez déjà tirer un bilan
là qu'on en parle encore un exemple du
défi que je soulève liées à la
coopération à l'institutionnalisation de
cette coopération en effectivement une
organisation apolitique 5 celle avec un
secteur permanent avec une force
conjointe qui était mis sur pied depuis
plusieurs années déjà pour venir à bout
de la question de la sécurité liée aux
groupes extrémistes violents et aussi un
certain nombre d'activités relevant de
la criminalité transnationale organisée
cette organisation aussi elle est
éliminée malgré la coopération malgré la
bonne volonté qui est souvent affiché
est laminée aussi souvent par des
problèmes lorsqu'il s'agit concrètement
d'opérationnaliser cette coopération la
haye les mines et aussi par an c'est
tellement de problèmes institutionnels
liés notamment aux moyens qui est une
sorte qu'ils sont nécessaires pour
mettre de prendre véritablement
personnel la force conjointe g500 il ya
des promesses qui ont été faites par et
ses partenaires internationaux mais qui
peine encore à se matérialiser sur le
terrain
lalor la presse conjointe est excellent
a déjà mené quelques opérations de
plusieurs opérations au niveau des coups
d'oeil frontale et des différents pays
mais on observe que malgré l'action de
cette de cette 17e cette action
régionale conjuguer aussi avec la scion
d'acteurs internationaux tels que la
france dans le cadre de l'opération
barkan ou encore de la milice maï dans
un certain dans une certaine mesure le
phénomène l'insécurité continue à
persister et même à se développer à 70
graphiquement donc encore effectivement
beaucoup pas faire du point de vue de la
coopération régionale du point de vue de
l'action aussi au niveau national merci
beaucoup je suis désolé on doit fermer
ce journal au manque de temps merci
beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous en direct
david jean merci